thank you
[Music]
Joe actually sent this to me yesterday
and I thought it was really interesting
yeah oh we should have had this for
lunch bro oh we're about to change lunch
again
so uh there's a tomb in the Philippines
a tomb yeah like you know dead guys
buried in it yeah but
you'll see what you'll see but it's an
interesting feature about it
here's what it looks like
oh [ __ ] are those Jollibee here lies
Jollibee Jones are those coffins what no
it's a tomb so like the dead it's like
uh so it's not a coffin but that's like
where the person's buried underneath the
mausoleum like I like that Jollibee do
you think it's a bunch of just like
fried chicken they throw in there too or
what so so the the story is actually
pretty touching like I was like aha
that's pretty funny and then I read it
and I was like dude it's [ __ ] dope So
like
um this Filipino family they never they
lived in an area that was very far from
Angelic B so they never even had it but
the um the father would cook them they'd
be like like fried chicken and they
would just call it jelly beans oh we're
having Jollibee they would do like a
weekly thing and then like eventually
like years and years later they actually
were able to like travel to one and have
it so it's like a memory in their family
that Jollibee was like kind of a thing
they would say and then it doesn't even
stop there every single year they paint
the tomb a different thing that's so
nice like a different fast food thing
not just a different thing that he liked
or something kind of like a beer or
something I don't know and then they
have the cost M M's they did a Ferrari
wow
I'm really excited super good right the
Jollibee one was my favorite because I
thought this dude worked at Jollibee
you will never leave Jolly I know and
then he's all like so you know how some
people are so about that brand yeah it's
like yo these are everything you know
it's like Mexican gangsters with the
Raiders merch like they love that stuff
I was dying this jersey they probably
get like a Raiders coffin and stuff you
know wouldn't I wouldn't put it by the
way for everybody in the Philippines I
had Jollibee a week a week ago and the
spicy fried chicken batter they got
there it's super spicy is it more
spicier than here is it a different one
yeah yeah they can yeah I don't know if
it's different I don't I don't go to
Jollibee in America more perfected in
the Philippines because they've been
doing it longer and it's locally sourced
all of them in like one Street in Manila
so yeah it's probably the best [ __ ] plus
chicken ethics out there are probably
different so they taste better yeah
ethics always makes food not as good I
know
it is Juicy out there that's why the
Halal Guys here is not as good as the
cart in New York yeah they got roaches
and rats the same grease from the whole
week yeah it makes food better but yeah
they uh this is their tradition where
they do things like this where they like
always decorate the you know like you
decorate grapes here yeah do you guys do
anything special for anything I don't go
to no graveyard dog [ __ ] that [ __ ]
that's such a cool Flex honestly the
only thing I feel like every single time
you go there and you just like clear all
like the Dead flowers or like the weeds
and you just try to like make the place
nice put something fresh there and
that's really it you know I don't have
any family members buried
it's cremation mainly yeah oh most so
did you scatter ashes in in Kuwait no my
grandma died in Japan and my mom was
like so we had the ceremony somewhere
somewhere and I was like that's cool and
I'm like I don't know where she's at
they have a cremation halls in Japan
yeah everything's cremation in Japan
because Taiwan is because Taiwan is only
cremation only because uh there's the
space is small but they have Halls where
you can put the ash into like a hall so
you can still go and pay respects they
don't have a hall they have a family
burial like box so like it'll be like a
tombstone thing yeah like one thing yeah
and then all of your ashes gets buried
into that one so you just use one plot
and then they write all your names into
that one thing yeah he has to burn stuff
that's tight that's like they do that
The Cremation one day it's like a scam a
little bit because because you gotta buy
the space in The Cremation thing and
then how much do they charge and they
forgot yeah I know but they'll go like
to 200 000 and you're not gonna be like
no you go okay
Joe oh yeah yeah yeah somebody your
family died you're not gonna be like
a good haul you know yeah that's why
that's why you gotta I know this sounds
weird but you buy it early when they're
like not dead already you like invest in
it early oh yeah yeah that's it's just
part of the industry it's a weird thing
like but like you know when like uh an
old family member already has a spot you
can already start paying for the spot
next to it oh in order to like minimize
that like one-time fee and then it's
weird like that don't you buy it for 50
years when you buy a spot I don't
remember it's like a 50-year wow
ownership uh you could just if I die
just throw me back into the East you
just want that yeah but sometimes it's
nice the family and friends together to
that's why to go to you know it's nice
to come together and then you can always
get a tombstone you know what I mean and
put it somewhere you guys all want to be
buried no hell no I'm gonna be a global
human being what does that mean global I
belong I belong everywhere so like it
just dusts my ashes in Japan Hawaii La
Vegas at the circus circus and uh one
strip club at the buffet the worst one
there's probably a lot of Ashes there
already a lot of great memories there
man Circus Circus is Amazing
[Laughter]
Joe is everywhere just slipping through
the filter just put me on a dollar bill
I'll [ __ ] circulate you know hey
that's true that's easy I don't I don't
know because
um I think just my family in general
there's no
um one city or one thing they've always
been moving and mobile right so like
most of their lives in Japan and then
the other half in America but then like
they go back and forth but also they
travel to different cities and in my my
uh closest relatives they also travel
like and moved in different parts
different states so we don't really have
like one city where I have Generations
you're a little Japanese Gypsy Nomads
pretty much I think uh I don't know if I
want to be buried but I know that my
family would because of Christianity and
they believe that like when God comes
you're gonna come out of your grave so
if you're not in your grave you just I'm
not gonna pop out of a urn yes
so I don't know I think they would want
me to so I think I would do it for that
reason
um Roy Rose Hills you're gonna stay
local I would like Billy Joe's Roseville
is kind of tight yeah that's nice easy
ease up there but most of my family's
buried in Forest lot the like the the
two one yeah because you're Filipino man
you're closer to the valley that's why
yeah that's what it is Filipinos go to
Forza all the time I don't know you guys
you guys want to do that whole
ceremonial [ __ ] like that getting the
the people coming to your funeral and
[ __ ] I just want to be forgotten
personally but I think my family would
and if I made a decision that they would
be more saddened later I would
[ __ ] probably become a ghost I'd
rather be stuck as a memory on YouTube
and in the digital world and then
um just be forgotten real quick
like move on that's how that's what
happens just put me on Instagram be like
R.I.P and then [ __ ] move on to
jacking off to [ __ ] only only fans or
something
that's your dying wish you wanted one to
jack off right after
um
people remember me and to have a great
time at my phone what if what if like
let's say but then that's if you died
now like what if you had kids right and
and the grandkids and they wanted
something to visit that's that's the
part where I think it's cool when the
whole family's together
um like because in that way like it
could become a theme for the family like
we visit my grandpa on like my birthday
Chinese New Year and stuff like that
yeah and it's always cool so he's buried
in Rose Hills and it's always cool to go
there and then there's already flowers
there I mean oh cool Auntie stopped by
whoever already stopped by you know we
just add our flowers to their flag that
makes sense that's that's a cool
tradition give birth to like a new
tradition yeah yeah and then the visit
all the joombies I'm gonna make all over
the world
mix yeah I said Joe
that you guys do where you guys visit
the grave of like your relatives or
anything like that there's no tradition
just you go whenever you you can go we
just go on like important dates so
birthdays uh New Years oh you guys you
go more than one time a year
because in Taiwan there's um the tunes
oh yeah we're supposed to go and clean
it it was tight I want doomsday before
Wednesday you see like people go there
and they spend because like you're
really trying to respect their Elders or
whatever so you you clean it people
bring a picnic and they spend the whole
day there that's cool and then you get
Tombstone Pizza
[Applause]
really
it's uh maybe it's because the kids
always complain but whenever we visit
our grandfather uh grandparents they're
in Hawaii but every single time you go
to visit them there's just all these
mosquitoes so like oh yeah everybody
just knows it's like when you get bit up
it's like oh you visited Grandpa and
that's just the thing so many mosquitoes
you don't want to be buried
I think I want to be cremated but at the
at the same time it's like
I it's more like also wanting to be with
your family if I had to make a decision
for myself as a human being selfishly
without any other context I'd probably
just want to be cremated but if it's
like my family's here or my grandparents
or my parents are it's like same thing
it's like just put me there my grandma's
cremated and buried oh so my grandpa so
so my uh my family always have so my
grandma my dad's side she passed away
young like before I was even born so
she's always been an urn because her ass
got cremated already and then so she was
just passed around from whatever the
family when the family immigrated here
she's just spending all these six to six
living rooms and then when my grandpa
passed away they the family wanted the
grandma and grandpa to be together so
they just put it in the car yeah I've
seen that too yeah so so the tombstone
has two names on it that's cool and
they're together but then one is a live
person the other one's powder yeah and
it's like inside the tombstone with them
yeah
that's kind of cool I think it's nice if
there's one place like that and two
places where the family is there so
family visit but also in a like a little
sand jar you could have it in your house
and be like this is Grandma in my room
you can do the sand the sand mixing
ceremony oh [ __ ] but you do it with
ashes yeah
together forever that's just weird you
just take each other's grandparents and
you're like let's bring the families
together and mix their ashes oh yeah
that's true marriage in a matcha
smoothie
and a little bit of Vagisil this this is
Joe's grandma
[Music]